if i treat you like you're
a plebe like you don't matter you're not
gonna respect me at all
spend time with yourself listen to your
instincts
maybe spend 10 minutes every morning
reading something that interests you
the first thing you have to do is you
have to work on your character
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn the six ways to get
people to respect
you more enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one give respect with jocko willink
how do you gain influence
and respect like what's that process
very similar to when we talked about
trust and building trust and
giving trust if i want to gain the
ability to influence you
well then what i have to do is give you
the ability to influence me
and when i say hey here's what we're
trying to make happen
here's what i want to do and you say
well i think we should do it like this
you know what i should say okay well
let's take a look at that
the more i allow you to influence me the
more open your mind gets for me to
influence you
so that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
allow you to influence me and the more i
allow that to happen
the more influence i'm gonna have
respect same thing
if i treat you like you're
a plebe like you don't matter you're not
gonna respect me at all
but if i treat you with respect and
respect you when you try and talk to me
i listen and i respect what you're
saying and i
try and understand it fully then
your respect for me is going to go up as
well so when you want to when you want
to earn respect give respect when you
want to earn influence give influence we
want to earn trust and give trust
all those three are related way number
two be the real you with mel robbins
remember in middle school when you'd be
sitting at the lunch table with your
friends
and you'd agree with just about anything
they said
in order to fit in and make sure they
thought you were cool well have you ever
sat down at a table with all your
friends now
and still feel like you can't be you
it might sound silly to think that
you're still dealing with this [ __ ]
as an adult but it's more common than
you think feeling like you can't be
yourself
or that you have to change who you are
in order to be liked is one of the most
normal pressures we feel but that
doesn't mean it's right
or that you have to live with it but if
you don't ever feel like yourself
what is the cost of fitting in do you
keep quiet
do you wear certain clothes do you act a
certain way or pretend to like things
that you don't
fitting in may make you think you're
safe and secure around
other people but are you really safe and
secure if you're creating distance from
your true self
the answer is no they call it peer
pressure because the desire to fit in
is putting pressure on you to be someone
you're not
now peer pressure is a concept that we
deal with our entire lives
it's so tempting to just stay quiet and
go with the group because
you think you're going to get invited
more you think you'll be accepted than
you would if you were just being you or
so you think
you know that uneasy feeling you have
when you can't be yourself
you're sitting there at the table but
you're not really there or you feel like
you're always
on the outside looking in at a group of
people
wondering why you don't feel like you
belong you got to pay attention to this
feeling because it means
you don't feel safe and secure being
yourself
and it also means you don't feel safe
and secure
with this group of people that
insecurity can stem from
a million things so let's just focus on
what you should do about it
first of all you have to stop putting
pressure on yourself to be somebody
you're not
you're not only robbing yourself of
enjoying your life you're robbing your
friends of enjoying the real
you now what i've come to learn is that
if you're pretending to be somebody
you're not
your friends are likely pretending to be
somebody they're not too
and if you don't stop this pressure to
conform in its tracks
you're going to end up having friends
that don't even know you
and worse you're going to start to feel
like you don't even know yourself
the more time you spend blending in
staying quiet pleasing the people around
you
the more you'll feel like you aren't
yourself that's the pressure
you're feeling right now now the first
step to being the real you
is getting to know yourself again and
it's going to sound
kind of weird but all you got to do is
spend time with yourself
listen to your instincts maybe spend 10
minutes every morning reading something
that interests you
go for a walk get started on a project
you've been thinking about
find something that energizes you and
set aside time to explore it on a daily
weekly or even a monthly basis
and here's the most important part start
talking about it with your friends
if you like different things or have
different opinions than your friends do
it doesn't make you wrong
we all have this knee-jerk reaction that
as soon as you're the odd one out
you're gonna get kicked out of the group
that's why you stay quiet
that's why you shrink in order to blend
in it's
[ __ ] you need to fight your fears in
order to be
yourself what if you getting real
is what your friend needed to find the
confidence to be real too
confidence doesn't come from your
friends liking the real you
confidence is knowing you'll be fine if
they don't
and if the people around you don't like
the real you
remember you can't change the people
around you
but you can change the people you're
around
the only thing you'll lose by being real
is something that's fake
so if you've been blending in since you
were a kid give yourself
permission to live as yourself it's a
gift you deserve right now
because in reality other people liking
you is a bonus
you liking yourself now that's the real
prize
way number three is listen more with ed
meidlet
one of the great things about my show is
that i've had to learn to listen more
and people say all the time one of the
reasons they like my shows i seem so
excited and so
interested in what people are saying
because i sincerely
am i've learned that being a great
listener is easier than being a great
talker
because being a great listener the
pressure's off you to come up with a
perfect thing to say
right the perfect response the perfect
phrase that sounds
smarter or better than somebody you
don't have to do that when you're a
great listener
and people's favorite topic number one
remember this people's favorite topic is
themselves they love to talk about
themselves
one of the things i've found over and
over in my life and my friends get a
kick out of this but when i play golf
you know you'll spend four or five hours
with somebody
when you're on a golf course and
oftentimes my friends will tell me man
dave really liked you ed like he really
enjoyed the time with you eddie
so much but he doesn't know anything
about you
and one of the reasons they like me so
much is i don't talk about myself i love
to talk about them i love to ask
questions about them and so it's
interesting
when we're done they really really like
me and they know nothing about me
and they wonder why they like me but the
reason they like me is i allowed them to
talk about themselves plus the fact
the way i look at life i already know
about me i'm not going to learn anything
else by talking about myself i'm going
to learn by
asking them questions about them and so
i think being a great listener has lots
of benefits one people will like you
more
two you're going to learn more three it
takes the pressure off you
and so listening skills are so critical
and even as we cover this you may say
i'm a great listener well
let's go through some things and see how
good we all are because even on my show
i'll be honest with you i watch replays
back of my show
and i interrupt too much i jump in too
much i finish people's sentences for
them too often
and that's an ego thing almost like i
think i can say it better than them in
fact i'm so bad at it i'll be honest
with you
before every show i tell them hey this
isn't like any other interview you've
been on before i'm going to interrupt
you you can interrupt me we'll make it
like a real conversation
and all of my guests always politely say
wonderful that's great i want you to cut
me off and
but the truth is that's not how a great
conversation goes it's not two people
interrupting each other all the time
it's one person talking another person
listening until they're finished
speaking
and then responding i love the book by
my brother evan carmichael built to
serve you guys this is the kind of thing
you get in this book
most people wake up and drive to a job
they hate think about your five closest
friends
are they happy do they live their lives
with purpose do you
we put on a fake front for what we want
people to see and think about us
but the reality is most people aren't
happy we're lost
we settle you can't be happy if you
don't know your purpose and then he goes
on to explain how to do that
you guys should get this book built to
serve by my dear friend evan carmichael
way number four be an inspiration to
someone with oprah winfrey
i remember when i started the school and
i said to my uh beloved uh friend maya
angelou i said maya
i'm so i'm just so proud that i was able
to create this school and i said this is
going to be my greatest legacy
and maya said to me you have no idea
all right you have no idea
what your legacy will be she said to me
because your legacy
is every life you've touched and that
shifted
the way i saw legacy or what you leave
behind
or what you do because maya was
explaining to me that
you know over all the years of watching
your show everybody who decided that
they were going to go back to school or
lose weight
or no longer hit their children or get
out of a bad marriage
all of those people who have seen and
experienced your voice
and the same thing with everybody here
you have no idea
what your legacy will be your legacy
is every life that you've touched and we
like to think of it i know
you have done amazing things with your
philanthropy
we like to think that these great
philanthropic moments are the ones that
leave the impact or will make the huge
difference in the world
but it's really what you do every day
it's how you
use your life to be a light to somebody
else's
you know and it's how you use your work
as an expression
of your own art whatever that is so i
don't i i think i would say the girls as
i get to watch them now
graduate from college and move into
their lives but really
there is a moment that uh that happened
to me
um just about a year after i went
national there was a woman in ann arbor
michigan
who wrote me a letter that will go on
my will i'm not gonna have a tombstone
but if i had a tombstone when cremated
it would go there um she said
oprah watching you be yourself every day
makes me want to be more of myself and i
just don't know
of anything better than that so i am
most proud of and just yesterday
i went to see uh notes from the field
with anna veersmith
and in the bathroom this woman comes up
to me
and says you know i've watched you all
these years
and you did so much for me and i used to
just hear people say oh i watch your
show i love you i love you watch your
show
and about 10 years in about the time i
started talking to the audience
i would stop people and say so tell me
what is it
what is it that moved you why why do you
love the show why do you
and this woman said to me just yesterday
you helped me to be more of myself
way number five respect yourself with
lisa nichols
emmanuel asks hey lisa i love your show
and he says can you go more in depth on
what
it means to show the world how it should
treat you
oh of course emmanuel i love this topic
um and and i love you too thank you for
your acknowledgment
so i i first said this
i first heard myself say this in 2007
when i was
at the honor of being on the oprah
winfrey show
and i remember saying it just kind of
fell out right and then
it was one of the highlights so i kept
seeing it replayed everywhere and it was
great that was replayed everywhere
because i kept seeing it again
and i kept hearing it again for myself
you know you say something like oh that
sounds good then you hear it back and go
oh i needed to hear that right it was
one of those things and it was
the world is following your example
of how the world gets to treat you and
it's your responsibility
to give the world the best example
possible the way you treat yourself
is the way i'm going to fall in order
and treat you as well so if you don't
give yourself any rest now
i want you as you're hearing me say this
i want you to just kind of
raise your hand or comment and you know
make a note if you
feel your truth popping up because this
is one of those things where the truth
just kind of opens up little by little
you go whoa
i didn't know that that was my behavior
or god thank god i've come a long way
so if you don't give yourself rest
then the world will think you don't need
rest in the world being
your family your friends if you say yes
to everything
then the world thinks right then the
world thinks
that you should say yes to everything
right
all of a sudden your yes actually has
less value because you give it away
so often this was a big aha that
right there is deep man i because i'm a
yes girl
you know i used to be a yes girl like i
just because i want to be liked right i
want to be liked and loved by everybody
so i'm like yes
yes yes and i give it away right and my
grandmother taught me she said baby
if you want your yes to have any value
you need to become more comfortable with
your no
that right there and that's a tweetable
moment
right if you want your yes to become
more valuable if you tweet it give
blanche houston the group
i can't even take the credit i i didn't
i thought no
you're being mean right no no means i'm
being
responsible at times because i say yes
even when i don't want to say yes so i'm
actually being unfair
to the people i'm saying yes to because
no one
wants your resentful yes right no one
needs or wants your overburden yes like
if they love you
they want your grateful yes yeah i'm
excited to do it
right and if if you're not excited to do
it or there's not even just a neutral
feeling
then don't give the yes up because it's
unfair to you and it's unfair to them
and so teaching the world how to treat
you you know has
everything to do with how are you
holding you
in esteem first how do you love and
honor you
you take that extra five minutes in the
shower just because you need that breath
do you turn the lights out at 10 o'clock
at night because you want to get eight
hours sleep
because if you're not willing to give
you eight hours sleep then i'm gonna
call you at midnight
right i'm gonna call you at five in the
morning cause i know you're up
right cause you get you you're always
going to be you gave me you gave me that
doorway
right and so learning how to teach
people how to treat you
the prerequisite to that is what does
falling
madly in love with you look like what
does
when i had to when i discovered what
falling madly in love with lisa looked
like
and it's not a braggadocious
ego-centered push the world away it
wasn't that
it was simply elevating and loving me
the way that i want to be loved giving
me
being the first in line right to treat
me well
and way number six the last one before a
very special bonus clip is work on your
character with eric thomas
so when you started talking about this
person ain't gonna do this you know
maybe i didn't do that but you you're
being selfish and anytime you're being
selfish
it's never going to be it's never going
to produce abundance
it's never gonna you're never gonna be
blessed so when people ask me
why i do what i do i don't lead you in
the wrong way
because i understand that if i do that i
can get some quick money but i'm not
into quick money i want to build a long
relationship
i want to build a solid foundation i
want us to be
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to work on your character because
what happens when you become
no disrespect but you look at these guys
who are making millions of dollars
playing sports
but then you hear the stuff that's going
on in a personal life that's because you
had a lot of talent but no character to
go with the talent
all right now i want to show i'm going
to show you how i blew up real quick all
right i want y'all to talk back to me
when you think about e.t and the brand
what are some of the things that you
think about
integrity that's a law
it takes it take it take longer to make
money doing
integrity to do to do the wrong thing i
grew up in detroit
my homies was doing the wrong thing they
was making big money quick and fast but
they don't have it no more
integrity take a while and that's why a
lot of us get discouraged because
you do it the right way and then you
don't see the money and then you quit
but to seize point
when you're building wealth versus
riches it's gonna take longer
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and how are you going to
take action on it
this week when you schedule in what day
what time and what place you're going to
take action you have a 91
chance of actually following through
versus just a 35
chance if you just got motivated but
never created a specific plan
and when you share your plan publicly
and have some accountability you
increase your chances even further of
actually following through so i want to
know your single biggest takeaway and
your plan of action this week
in the comments so i can celebrate you
you train the people in your life how to
treat you
if you are not happy with the way
something is going in your life with how
somebody is treating you
it's not their fault it's not their
fault for walking all over you it's not
their fault
for being a loser an idiot or uncaring
it's your fault for allowing it to
happen
to you and you need to raise your
standards
and teach the people in your life how to
treat you now i'm not talking about
as a child and child abuse and all those
things like at some point
you know you're too young to be able to
make those decisions but if you're an
adult
you always have a choice you are not
powerless
you teach the people in your life how to
treat you
and if you're not happy with it then you
need to raise your standards
one of the things for me as an example
is punctuality
i hate when people are late and i'm
never late for things
i value my time time is the most
precious thing that i have
and so i value it immensely and if you
are late for something for me
that's going to really bother me that's
going to be a problem and i'll respect
your time in the process as well so when
i first started working with alex
at toronto dance also as an example he
would routinely be late
not really late but 15 minutes late 10
minutes late
five minutes late he'd be late that's a
problem for me
don't be late come in and meet me
i value my time you should value yours
as well
and so when it kept happening i locked
the door and you couldn't get in you'd
have to go
work somewhere else you waste even more
time
and we had conversations if you are
making a goal to show up at a certain
time and then you show up
late you're missing another goal you're
letting yourself down not just me not
just the people that you're
setting these times up you said you're
letting yourself down if you booked a
coffee meeting with me
for three o'clock on a thursday
afternoon and you don't show up
at three o'clock by three o'clock i'm
out
because you shouldn't just be there at 3
o'clock you really should be there 15
minutes early
because i'm there 15 minutes early you
should not be there at 3 o'clock
when i do hangouts on my youtube channel
i do more on the live channel than the
main one
if we're supposed to start at 2 o'clock
we start at two o'clock i send you the
link 10 to 15 minutes before we start
if you don't show up at time at two
o'clock
then i leave i cancel it and if you
showed up at 201
you would have missed it i'm not there
anymore i'm gone
no five minute rule or ten minute rule
or 15 minute rule i'm gone
and that's with some customers right
like that means i don't do business with
some people
that means i lose out on some deals if
i'm supposed to meet somebody at a
coffee shop
at three o'clock and they're not there
by three o'clock and i leave
and they come five minutes later i'm
gone
they wasted their afternoon they're
probably not gonna be super happy about
that
i may not make a deal with that person
one if that's the kind of relationship
we're gonna have i don't wanna do
business with that person
if you're gonna routinely be late to
things i don't wanna deal with you
two if we're gonna reschedule something
you're not gonna be late for me the next
time
and so you teach the people in your life
how to treat you
because you have a new standard that you
value yourself to such a degree that you
say i am not willing to let you walk all
over me anymore
you need to set up a higher wall a
higher barrier
and so yes the people around you may be
taking advantage of you they may be
treating you like crap they may be
hurling insults at you
you need to stop allowing it to happen
stop blaming them
for their insecurities and their issues
stop blaming them
take ownership stop letting it happen to
you
demand respect
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below or if you want
to know the tricks to get people to like
you
immediately check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there